the massacre was only the beginning who  did this to us who attacked the tribe  all we can do is pray to the goddess no  praying won't save us we have to find  the killers so you will have to leave  the sacred land where the trail leads  I will go  a lawyer vanora what brings you to  Meridian there's a threat to us all men  in masks raising up ancient machines and  I've seen their leader from the depths I  will raise an arm a storm of shadows to  take back what's ours  what's it doing to that take control you  can see the crappy balance  come a long way since the sitter - Leroy  who are you an interested party  race payload size now  so it comes to this  what is it at the end or how it begins  anyway  there's so much more to discover before  the world ends